we were supposed to do a little
interview off of the flow but I got
replaced for somebody which I completely
understand yeah I'm sorry I had to
better people you I just met Justin
Trudeau never here
I mean I can accept getting bumped for
Justin Trudeau back that's acceptable
what did you and Justin talk about he we
just talked about life and our
backgrounds and everything he was so
nice he's the best hugger like he like
hugs you like when you know what like
someone like hugs you and like they grab
you it was a hug I mean he was so lovely
he was so engaging we talked and then we
took pictures and you know when you like
meet someone and you take pictures
that's usually the end of it we took our
pictures and he was like so anyway and
he just kept talking and I was like oh
it's over like still having a
conversation that is so cool
his staff was lovely here so many LGBTQ
people on a staff and they were all so
casual like you didn't realize you were
meeting the leader of a country like
everyone's in shorts and t-shirts and
like rainbow stuff and it was just it
was lovely that's what I could not have
asked for a better experience that is
epic and it is Shawano pride which is
amazing how does it feel to come back
for Toronto pride as Brooklyn Heights
from RuPaul's Drag I'm a it's been five
years five years since I've been back
and it just feels incredible and to come
back in this way it's just phenomenal I
could not be happier I'm having the best
time I was at Dundas Square last night
Oh God and your career out there quelled
surfer I was crying crash serves I knew
I had to it's kind of like the season 11
thing everybody's been doing it like
plastique doesn't banjee doesn't steal
keep it it god bless her you do it the
best
everybody's been doing it but it's just
crazy it's like a thing I'm doing I know
you're busy touring I know you're
running around but with Brooklyn ever do
a one-woman show where you do ballet
and you do different types of grab
solutely honestly like there are so many
irons in the fire right now there are so
many things happening I can't talk about
any of them whatever right there's
there's a lot of them there's a lot of
thing and exciting things happening and
a lot of doors opening and I'm just kind
of I'm not saying no to anything right
now and honestly I don't really know
what the future holds for me yeah I just
I'm kind of just going with the flow and
like trying everything once I mean
that's what you do right you go with the
flow I'm looking back on the experience
of RuPaul's Drag Race any regrets I mean
no no no I you know when everything
happens for a reason everything it's
meant to be so I'm living my life I'm
having an amazing time it has completely
changed my world whether I won or lost
like that's not that's not the point of
the show for me the point of the show is
what you get out of it and where it can
take you and it's taking me amazing
places and I'm just so grateful for
everything well I mean you were doing
incredible things for Canada just having
that representation we talked about this
before but it's amazing like you are the
queen of the Noor I am I'm so grateful
I'm so proud to be part of this country
I'm so proud to be Canadian like it just
makes me like I know I gotta mention
where we're on right now isn't that
incredible this is the first time I've
ever been on a float in bribe this is my
second time this is a much better
experience
for the last time was world Pride and I
was in a giant headdress and a giant
back piece and I was standing on the
back of the float for eight hours I was
miserable and right now I am in a flowy
Grecian
this is a much better experience I'm so
happy to be partnering with lift lifts
just added a new thing to there
laptop you can choose your pronoun now
so you can choose what you would like to
be referred to as your driver which is
incredible I mean I feel like this
should have happened so long ago my god
so long ago it's such a simple gesture
and it's such an easy thing but it just
makes everybody feel a little bit more
I know people are probably asking you
every second
it's all-stars 5 on your radar would you
do it if not send us like 20 times
that's like asking a woman who just had
a baby do you want another baby like
yeah but like in a couple years
all Thursday's yeah like all stars each
one like once we do our reality show
also
like in a minute like I don't need it
right now like I'm doing good yeah like
but in a couple years maybe yeah
I'm not saying again you'd never say no
to anything I feel like you kind of just
need to continue with where you're at
right now and how you build exactly your
shoe that's what I'm gonna do all I
always love chatting to you I could talk
to you forever
I mean this is incredible crazy I'm so
excited to get out there because it's
real gay yeah this is real gay I love it
finally I wanna lose with shangela
yesterday yes I saw I'm jealous I love
her sing your praises oh she was just
fabulous but I want to know what is
pride made to Brooklyn Heights
pride is a special time of year for me
because this is actually when I came out
to my family back when I was I believe
18 I came out to my mom and dad at pride
so it's not always a special kind of
year it just means celebrating who we
are coming together as a community and a
reminder that there's so much further
there's so much more work to do as a
community we have so much more to do in
terms of tolerance and acceptance and
just equality it's all about equality
all anybody wants in the world is the
city the same as anybody else we thought
we deserve equal rights equal healthcare
equal pain for everybody across the
board bar none and I know that's not it
so much of an issue in Canada but I'm
seeking more so about America but
there's where's work to be done
everywhere just for total equality for
all it's such a simple concept but I
think that's just all what anybody wants
at the end of the day I love catching up
with you and you've become a friend
which is awesome I know I'm like
checking in with you I'm like where's my
text now all the time so yeah it's
awesome well happy pride and keep
spreading the good word of love and
compassion
thank you baby I love you